Das elektrische universum oft auch als plasma version bezeichnet ist ein universum in dem die vorgänge im kosmos nicht von der gravitation
bestimmt sondern von der elektromagnetischen kraft sterne beispielsweise sollen durch elektrizität
Betrieben werden das bild des kosmos dass wir seit. Jahrhunderten haben wird. Also komplett auf den. Kopf gestellt was steckt wirklich hinter dieser, hypothese
Und welche pro. Und contra argumente gibt es bezüglich eines plasma versus und ist tatsächlich unser wissen zur
Gesamten naturwissenschaft falsch. Ihr habt vielleicht schon eine ahnung dass alles. Noch viel mehr jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ein themenvorschlag über die messenger whatsapp. Und so weiter vielen dank. Dafür wer dabei sein könnt und themen vorschlagen können
Und vor allem die unzuverlässige abo box von youtube überlistet das erfahrt. Ihr am ende des videos
das eine modell zum elektrischen universum oder zur plasma
kosmologie gibt es nicht wirklich statt dessen gibt es unzählige filme bücher
Und behauptungen dazu die sich in den einzelheiten allerdings stark unterscheiden auch. Wo genau der ursprung dieser idee zum
universum liegt es ungewiss
883 jedenfalls wurde ein aufsatz zum thema in neuseeland von einem autoren mit dem pseudonym
Torpedo verfasst ich sage explizit aufsatz denn. Hierbei handelt es sich. Keinesfalls
Um, irgendeine wissenschaftliche arbeit demnach ist die elektrizität für alles im universum
verantwortlich erst durch elektrische vorgänge können die sterne leuchten
Und sie die planeten bewegen auch weitere arbeiten zum elektrischen universum auf die sich ihre anhänger berufen stammen nicht von
Astronomen oder astronomen physikern oder physikerin das ganze netz ist voll von seiten auf denen verschiedene thesen zum thema aufgestellt werden
Einig sind sich die anhänger. Und anhängerinnen aber zumindest in den folgenden punkten
Im elektrischen universum gibt es kein urknall stattdessen wird, behauptet dass das universum viel kleiner sei als angenommen
und zudem statisch b auch die sterne werden durch elektrizität
angetrieben der hypothese des elektrischen universums zufolge sind sterne elektrische
transformatoren zu dem
Gebären sie elektrisch, andere. Sterne und gasplaneten so entstehen auch erdähnliche planeten
Um, und zwar durch, einen elektrischen ausstoß aus gas giganten
Planeten neben umlaufbahn an die der geringsten elektrischen beeinflussung entsprechen ja das universum expandiert nicht
Und galaxien bestehen aus elektrizität
Die krater auf himmelskörpern sind spuren elektrische entladung die die großen gaswolken
Und supernova reste sind plasma ströme im universum. Ihr merkt also was die moderne astronomie seit jahrzehnten annimmt ist nach den
Vorstellungen der anhänger des elektrische universums falsch demnach ist einfach alles
Elektrizität forschungsteams weltweit jedenfalls sehen das alles als eine große verschwörungstheorie gemischt mit ein 10 pseudowissenschaft
Und darüber haben wir in anderen videos von kriegs- und science fiction ja zur genüge berichtet
Verschwörungstheorien sind so abstrus dass es schwerfällt angemessen darauf zu reagieren quasi so als wenn
Euch jemand erzählen würde das gras ist nicht grün sondern lila
was soll man anfangen mit solchen argumenten
Doch fest steht die theorie des elektrischen universums widerlegt komplett unser wissen und die forschung zu den gravitative wechselwirkung
Und sind wir mal ehrlich damit lassen, sich alle phänomene auf der erde erklären die mit schwerkraft
Zu tun haben, auch die bewegung der himmelskörper wie lässt sich damit vorhersagen
und sogar neue planeten lassen
Sich mit diesem wissen ich sag nur planet 10x oder 9 oder wie wir und auch immer nennen wollen damit
Konnten wir 2006 eine raumsonde in richtung eines leeren punkte schicken, weil wir berechnen. Konnten dass sie dort
zehn jahre später auf pluto treffen wird natürlich kann es sein dass wir die gravitation
Noch nicht, zu 100 prozent verstanden und beschrieben haben aber natürlich lässt das nicht den. Umkehrschluss
Zu dass alles dazu falsch ist dazu. Kommt die. Theorie des elektrischen universums beschreibt den
Kosmos nicht mal annähernd so gut es gibt. Keine mathematische
Formel mit der man, beispielsweise die bewegungen der planeten. So gut vorhersagen kann wie mit unserem wissen zur gravitation. Und das wurde
jahrzehntelang durch unterschiedliche beobachtungen methoden bestätigt, und herausgefunden viele anhänger
Und anhängerinnen sind der ansicht dass sich seriöse wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler extra unsinnigen theorien zum universum ausdenken
um die angeblichen fakten zum elektrischen universum
Zu unterdrücken ein beispiel in einem aufsatz heißt es dass sonnenflecken kühler sind als ihre
Umgebung doch dies würde von der modernen astronomie geleugnet stattdessen hätten sonnenflecken etwas mit elektrizität
Zu tun deswegen sei auch die sonne elektrisch wir. Alle wissen aber dass moderne forschungsteam sehr. Wohl beobachtungen, und messungen dazu machen und natürlich
ignorieren sie die kühleren temperaturen der sonnenflecken nicht
genauso wenig wie sie magnetische
Und elektrische felder in ihren erklärungen auch nicht ignorieren ja doch nur. Weil
Dieser teilt eine theorie ist heißt es noch lange nicht das alles
Elektromagnetisch ist eines muss lernen den. Anhängern des elektrischen universums lassen, ihre. Hypothesen sind simpel und genau das wird auch der grund sein weswegen
Ihre anhänger lieber an sie als an komplizierte wissenschaftliche
erklärungen glauben aber mal ganz ehrlich
Wie sollten sich wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler. So komplexe
Theorien mit mathematischen riesigen konstruktionen ausdenken können wenn. Sie. Keinen realen hintergrund hätten ja wenn
Ihr kein video zur bullshit theorien und zu einem anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich beim whatsapp und den anderen messengern nur dann verpasst
Er kein video denn die abo box auf youtube das wisst
Ihr ja die ist immer ziemlich lückenhaft über die messenger erfahrt. Ihr von mir. Noch vor allen. Anderen vom
Neuesten videos liegt also vorher eine nachricht täglich garantiert einfach hier draufklicken. Und zur begrüßung habe ich. Ein kleines goodie für euch
Und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal. Krieg zum. Social media abonnieren es geht auch
Hier darf hat er das neueste aus der social media welt aktuell die anhörung von mark, zuckerberg
Vor dem europäischen parlament aber nicht die glocke, einen job aber nicht
Genau, wie glocke vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken. Kopf einschalten bei schwert
Verschwörungstheorien das kann ich nur wärmstens empfehlen ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt dran